well we have new details this morning
about the health of American diplomats
who are victims of a possible sonic
attack in Cuba medical records reviewed
exclusively by CBS news show some
diplomats suffered conditions as serious
as mild traumatic brain injury Cuba's
government denies any involvement saying
quote it is never nor would it ever
allow action against accredited
diplomatic agents but the attacks appear
to be continuing an executive editor
Steve Dorsey from our CBS news radio
network broke this story and joins us
from Washington Steve good morning good
morning an American doctor who diagnosed
the diplomats conditions which include
possible damage to the central nervous
system is warning about the health risks
of future exposures the problems are
believed to have been caused by a sonic
device this is unprecedented the State
Department says it's taking the health
attacks against the US diplomats very
seriously we are working and have been
working to provide our staff and US
government employees with the best
medical attention since late last year
US and Canadian diplomats in Havana have
complained of hearing loss nausea
headaches and balance issues now new
documents show some ended up suffering
mild brain injury the State Department
confirms some diplomats were medically
evacuated to Miami for treatment and
testing are there any that are still in
Cuba that have been affected by this who
have asked the State Department to leave
some we asked to leave because their
condition necessitated that there were
others that have chosen to stay there
the State Department has also sent
medical professionals to Havana to
assess us staff while it hasn't
identified a source of the attacks it
did expel two Cuban embassy officials in
response we held the Cuban authorities
responsible for finding out who his
carrying out these health attacks
officials are investigating whether the
injuries could have come from a type of
covert sonic device targeting diplomats
homes directed by the Cuban government
well this could only have been
accomplished by the Cuban intelligence
service as far as I can as far as I know
Brian littell served in the CIA and
specialized in Cuban relations for 35
years if this activity doesn't
completely cease then I think the Cubans
may wind up paying paying an additional
cost in terms of the nature of the
diplomatic relationship one source
familiar with the incidents tell CBS
News US diplomats have had their
vehicles vandalized homes broken into
and been under constant surveillance
Florida senators Rubio and Nelson have
requested a classified briefing into
these health attacks go alright Steve
thank you